Running us
right now is
James Cameron Diver, Explorer,
director of The Abyss,
a deep sea
thriller, and most famously,
of course, Titanic,
as well as well as many other
great films.
James, I appreciate you joining us.
Someone who's devoted his life
to exploration,
as you have
in many ways under the sea and wondering
what is going through your mind tonight.
Well, thanks, Anderson.
I mean, obviously,
we're all
we're all kind of heartsick
from the outcome of this.
And I've been living with it
for a few days now
as some of my other colleagues
in the deep submergence community
I was out on a ship myself
when the event happened on Sunday.
The first I heard of
it was Monday morning.
I immediately got on my network
because it's a very small community
in the deep submergence group
and found out some
information within about a half hour
that they had lost comms
and they had lost
tracking simultaneously.
The only scenario
that I could come up with
in my mind that could account for
that was it was an implosion, a shockwave
event so powerful
that it
actually took out a secondary system
that has its own
its own pressure vessel
and its own battery power supply,
which is the
transponder that the ship uses to track
where the sub is.
So I was thinking implosion then.
That's Monday morning.
I got on the horn again
with some other people,
tracked down some intel
that was probably of a military origin,
although it could have been research
because there are hydrophones
all over the Atlantic
and got confirmation
that there was some kind of loud noise
consistent with an implosion event.
That seemed to me
enough confirmation
that I let all of my inner
circle of people know that we
had lost our comrades.
And I
encourage everybody to
to raise a glass in their honor
on Monday.
Then I watched over the ensuing days
this whole sort of everybody
running around with their hair on fire
search,
knowing full
well that it was futile,
hoping against hope
that I was wrong,
but knowing in my bones that I wasn't.
And so it certainly
wasn't a surprise today.
And I just feel terrible for the families
that had to go through all of these
false hopes that kept getting dangled,
you know, as it played out.
You've I just want to to
you said it was on Monday
that you learned
of these these
listening devices
underwater had picked up
the sound of an implosion
or what was believed.
Yeah, that's that's as it came to me.
Now, that's hearsay. Multiple, you know,
they were credible sources.
So, you know,
I took that as a factor
that I multiply it in
with the other factors.
And I couldn't
think of any other scenario.
In which a sub would be lost
where it lost comms and navigation
at the same time and stayed out of touch
and did not surface.
I was also told,
and I don't have confirmation on this,
that they had they were on descent.
There were a couple hundred meters
above the sea floor
and they dropped their weights.
Now, the only way for the ship to know
that they had dropped
their ascent way
to be an emergency aboard
is if they had called that in,
that they were they were ascending.
So I,
I believe now that they had some warning
that they heard
some acoustic signature of the hull
beginning to laminate.
An investigation
will hopefully eventually show what
what did happen
because we all need to know
as we go forward, the deep
submergence community needs to know
exactly what happened
You've made dozens
of I mean, just extraordinary
deepwater expeditions,
including more than 32.
The Titanic cell itself
you've also gone
far deeper than the 13,000 feet
where the Titanic is.
I think you've gone
deeper than just
about anybody into the ocean.
I wrote it into
I forgot the name of the place
you went, the challenger deep.
Which Challenger did
you went in your own design.
Yeah.
You went in your own designed craft.
That's a submersible
that was experimental
and didn't
go through
the sort of the standard
safety protocols.
But the difference is
you were not taking passengers on board.
Would you ever have taken passengers
on board a submersible that had not gone
through the standard
maritime safety protocols?
No, not at all.
I mean, my sub that I went to the
to the Challenger
Deep dove safely three times deeper than
then Titanic.
We made
multiple dives in that in that sub.
That sub was a single seater
and it was only contemplated that myself
and the engineer
with whom I co-designed
the vehicle would be the only
pilot of that sub.
And we worked on it for seven years.
We knew every detail of it intimately.
I was involved
in every phase of the testing.
So, you know, I assessed the risks.
I understood them very well.
And those were risks
I was willing to take.
I would never take it upon myself
to ask someone else
to take that type of risk.
And if I were designing
a multi seat vehicle
where I intended to be
the pilot,
we'd go through
all of the rigorous test protocols
and review protocols
that you have
with, let's say, Airbus,
which is the American Bureau of Shipping
or DMV or German Lloyd's,
who are the major
bureaus that the Class
A sub,
they call it classing,
but it's basically certification.
And I think it was unconscionable
that that this group
did not go through that rigorous process
What is you know, this was a
an experimental design.
There's no question about it.
It's a carbon composite.
You can tell us more about what
that actually means.
I mean, it's
the kind of stuff used in spacecraft,
but is it designed
for deep underwater pressure?
And what is the
what is the danger
of that kind of material
in this kind of environment?
It's completely inappropriate for
for a vessel that sees external pressure.
You know,
carbon fiber composites are used
very very successfully
for internal pressure, pressure
vessels like, let's say, a scuba tank.
And you can get two or three times
multiple of what
you could get out of steel
or aluminum
for for that type of pressure bottle.
But for something
that's seeing external pressure,
all of the advantages of composite
materials
go away
and all the disadvantages come into play.
So if you're using a uniform material
like steel or titanium or ceramic
or acrylic,
you can do
computer modeling
with a high degree of accuracy
and confidence.
The second you start
doing carbon composite
or any kind of composite materials,
you're introducing to materials
that are in contact with each other,
the filament itself,
and then the epoxy matrix
that it that it sits within.
And at that point
you have degradation failure.
So we always understood
that this was the wrong material
for submersible hulls,
because with each pressure cycle,
you can have progressive damage.
So it's quite insidious
because you may have
a number of successful dives,
which is what happened here,
and then have it fail later.
If I were diving in a sub
that that was fully certified,
I wouldn't think about it.
But even in my own sub,
which had a steel hull,
I knew that if I,
if I drove several two or three times
it was probably good to go
because you could cycle steel
hundreds of times,
if not thousands of times.
But that's not the case with composite.
So it's it's quite insidious.
And that,
I think, lulled them
into a sense of confidence
and led to this tragedy.
But these are known things.
They're known within
the engineering community and they're
well, we
also want to point to Ocean Gates, former
director of Marine Operations.
He wrote us an engineering report in 2018
I think it was
he focused his criticisms
on the company's decision
to rely on acoustic monitoring
the sounds the hull made under pressure
as opposed to a a scan of the hall.
According to him
the company claimed no equipment existed
that could perform
that kind of a scan
on the five inch thing
five inch thick carbon fiber hull.
I know it's
difficult to say obviously
without reading the report,
but I'm wondering what you make of that
because the
seems like this company
was making a big deal
about the sensors they had that could
sense a problem with the hull.
And if they could sense
there was a problem,
then they would have time to
to to turn around and go back up.
Clearly, they did it.
It's a bit like saying we have
we have a bit of a poor design
for the engine in our jet
or our rocket ship.
But we have a sensor that will
tell us if it's on fire.
To me, that's cold comfort.
And I think that if you're
if you're building a hall
where you need
to have sensors to tell you
that it's failing
in the process of failing,
you have no business
designing subs
or being in that in that sub.
They touted it, I believe you know,
as a as a good thing,
as a as a safety protocol.
But I consider it a bad thing
because it sheds a light
directly on
on the fundamental flaw
of their of their design.
You have to remember,
the DNA of this design
concept goes back farther.
It goes back to the quest
to go to the challenger
deep that I was involved in, obviously.
And there was another sub design
that was competing with ours at the time
that was based on a wound filament
composite cylinder
with two titanium caps.
And I told those guys point blank,
you're going to get killed in that thing.
And they ultimately never drove it.
I literally told the guy
who bought the sub
when its owner,
Steve Fossett, the famous
billionaire, died in a plane crash
and the sub was then
purchased by another guy to operate it.
And I told him,
you're going to die down there
if you dove that thing.
And I felt very strongly about it.
I had nothing to do with Ocean Gate,
and I never warned,
tried to warn, Stoked
and Rush of the same thing
because I thought
maybe they've solved it, you know?
But I was pretty opinionated about it
at the time.
And they had a similar idea
of doing acoustic sensors, too.
They call it D Lamination
when water ingress starts
to force the layers
of the of the fibers apart.
And theoretically you can hear it.
I actually believe
they heard it with their ears,
not through the sensor system
in the last moments of their lives.
And that's quite a horrifying prospect.